it was just a few weeks before Christmas
when Kristin Cavallari got the
devastating news her brother Michael had
been found dead after wandering off into
the desert she said at that time her
heart was in a million pieces and now
Kristin has written a new book about her
life and she opened up to our Jennifer
Parros about losing the brother that she
misses so dearly I just want to offer my
condolences about passing your brother
how are you doing I'm okay you know I
mean I have good days and bad days but
I've really found a lot of strength in
my kids I mean I had Saylor at the same
time my brother went missing and then
ultimately passed away and so you know I
was just I couldn't I couldn't collapse
I had a newborn baby to look after had
to be strong for her and for my whole
family her family is her anchor but this
mom of three admits relationships can be
tough she and husband of almost three
years Chicago Bears quarterback Jay
Cutler have to work at it I'm very
honest about the fact that you know we
have problems we don't have a perfect
relationship you're really open when
you're talking about therapy that you
guys have problems just like any other
normal couple yeah and therapy is
something that really helps you guys
yeah absolutely I mean we still see our
therapist occasionally and we've picked
up really great tools from her the one
time reality star of the hills and
Laguna Beach couldn't be busier a
successful line of shoes and jewelry
have made her a fashion staple now her
new book balancing in heels offers an
open look into her life including her
own body image issues luckily I never
had a severe eating disorder you know I
did every diet and I was always counting
calories and I was beating myself up
anytime I would binge eat or whatever
and it was a horrible way to be and then
when I got pregnant with my first son
Camden I decided okay I'm gonna enjoy
being pregnant I'm gonna indulge but
everything I eat is gonna be real food
you said that you probably will never
try Botox I just don't think we know the
long-term effects of all all that stuff
never say never I never know I could be
40 going and I take back everything I
said now before the birth of Saylor
Kristen told us that she was kind of
scared about having three kids all under
the age of four yeah but like everything
in her life she's making it look easy
now